[Music]
all right I have a story from reddit and
it's not an MIT [ __ ] it's actually a
relationship advice subreddit I'm down
you're the worst people to ask oh yeah I
need advice I just always have I'm just
wrong the men in relationships are
always wrong thank you what did I do
wrong just look down to the ground and
say yes I was wrong you know you know
how you're right you know how you could
be right it's just don't be in a
relationship then you're right then
you're always right problem if you don't
have the problem that's who you're right
I've never been tested yeah I'm sick but
I don't know if it's growing up you'll
never find out mm-hmm all right so this
story that I have here it's about this
28 year old man who went on reddit and
is asking for advice cuz he's like no
what do I do I like help people do this
already on reddit yeah well I actually
think it's a good idea cuz you're
anonymous there's like non bias and
there's a pond of people yeah I give
opinions that's true yeah so it's like
the like just here's the problem and
here like a bunch of angles right
exactly like that's that and might be
[ __ ] be nice I want it I wanted to
start app like that like five years ago
jump on my dick face in Maya dictates
all right so this story here he was
saying that he was planning on proposing
to his girlfriend who they've been
together for three years and he was like
I really suck at picking out jewelry so
I asked her best friend if she could
come over and help me out like pick out
some jewelry because the girlfriend had
stepped out for the day
yeah that's already the wrong move
anything because already feels like
sketchy now no I mean it's fine normal
sketchy that means there's on the woods
but it was played out like a portal like
she came over just like I like this
jewelry and then you could see her but
her bun sticking out of it you telling
me late she lays out all the Rings on
his dick okay can we have sex and can
you tell me if she would like this on
our wedding night should I do it like
this like this porno writers are the
best I should be one anyway back to this
actually did you only change your arms
you just crossed her legs or something
like that you start this way did you
Ghanim style the chicken burger
oh my god I'm gonna try it next no gone
on style here we took it over guys did
you guys smell in Alabama they don't
have reverse cowgirl and they have sex
yeah because you should never turn your
back on family
all right are we ready back okay so he
ends up inviting her best friend and
like I said the girlfriend was planning
on like going somewhere else for that
date so then the boyfriend asked the
girlfriend she was like hey or he was
like hey um what time are you planning
on coming back because I'm gonna order
food and I want to make sure to time it
by the time you get back home and then
she was like oh I'm actually gonna be a
few hours I ended up going with her best
friend Justine oh yeah so she Oded she
was with her best friend when he was
with her best friend that's pretty much
like the bottom row so that now the
boyfriends like he's like Wyatt wait it
says she's with Justine but just seems
laying naked in my bed right now I don't
like just they stop sucking my dick
she says she's with you like it sounded
like they Chappelle saying it can you
believe she's cheating on me I know
right that's so gross why would she do
that to you dude this is all kinds of oh
man so that's why that's why would she
be lying she ends up saying I'll write
it like dude we have like zero secrets
we have the best relationship what if
she surprising him with something maybe
we're not that way babe were just
jumping to the worst conclusion ever
most cynical maybe she wants to propose
the end because we're very forward like
that now women are powerful and she's
going out to get him
maybe she's with his best friend
practicing [ __ ] skills that she's
nasty
do you think you'll like this joke a I
do it like this or like this wedding
don't do that to the boss oh yeah so
this poor guy he's just like I don't
know what to do like we have zero trust
issues we tell each other everything
like I want to ask her so bad but then
if I tell her that I knew she was lying
then it's gonna give away my whole
surprise proposing to her I would like
to send the best friend in you know be
like hey what are you up to today
is at that point if she she can't say
I'm with you yeah she wouldn't like to
but maybe she would well then you know
it's a real problem with that point yeah
it was a good thing that's right it was
a good thing she would said the best
friend that's genius
she should have be cheating on you
that is so [ __ ] up you're right here
trying to get a ring for her and I can't
believe this [ __ ] into a portal it's
just that much better anyway so then I
just like my area it hurts so bad the
dick whacked her earring and orally I
was sort of slept invisible dick Oh hot
in there well this guy ended up like
this thing had like a ton of comments of
so many people were telling him like
she's cheating on you just end it just
[ __ ] ended don't even tell her
anything all this stuff right and so he
ends up giving an entire update post and
so he says that he decided to confront
his girlfriend and then he did think
about using some of the lies that people
were suggesting but then he was like
this just wouldn't even make sense so he
ended up telling her the reason why
justine was there and like he was like
so why were you lying so it turns out
that she was surprising him with a snake
cuz he want he's always wanted a snake
and so she always said that she was like
never live in a house of the snake and
but he's like because he was like some
people are cat people some people are
dog people well I'm a snake person and
so that's so [ __ ] funny wholesome
thing why would you ever think that I
would cheat on you I was handling a
snake but I wasn't like posting a photo
got a snake she was like this is the
only photo I have cuz the other one has
my girlfriend's face right next to it
but so he told her that he was going to
propose at that point yeah he can't
cancel ruin the surprise and so now she
he's like Janna she just keeps picking
on me like thankfully picking like oh so
we're gonna get married so what rain are
you gonna pick they could have a snake
be the ring bearer put it on the tail oh
that was a lot more wholesome than with
I know he was like I'm sorry for just
pointing a lot of you guys you guys
thought it was gonna be a nice juicy
ending not just the snake that's cute
there are just some wholesome people out
there by some people sometimes I just
meet people and I'm like and you're like
raised by the Bible or something you
know like you've never been [ __ ]
before that's right there are some
people like that I just I always wonder
like what is your sex life like you know
it might be how wild yeah right and my
sister what that's where they like
manifest all the craziness or they could
just be like missionaries too crazy over
missionary the sticking your dick
through the pee hole I just keep it all
the clothes on and then you [ __ ]
through the bedsheet this is pilgrim sex
this is how they did it back then mm-hmm
well that's according to The Handmaid's
Tale
you have to read a Bible verse and then
you have to [ __ ] have a Sarah Bodi
the hens made the head me tell ya can
only have sex in the confession box
because you have to confess while having
sex I do not like this I just want this
for children I'm so sorry father
well that's got a hot cut a hole in a
confection okay Gloria Hall the holy
goalie it's a holy hole oh my god I am a
genius it's a holy hole you're inventing
a new job 30 something or four I always
forget the number anyway reminder the
scene from my euro trip yes my mayoral
trip that sounds familiar
see a one time early remember I just
remember one scene where they pick up a
weird guy in the train and like every
time they go through a tunnel it's dark
and the guy gets closer is going through
the confession booth till I confess now
I know where she sees like in the in the
window that's pressed against it and it
was a couple having sex in the other
side Yeah right like what it's like for
people have you guys seen that couple
were they didn't do anything until I got
married they even kiss really the first
time they kiss it was really weird
we covered a reddit post about like the
couple never having sex and then they
got married and they had sex and it was
like terrible Tara no no the guy had a
micropenis that's what I would be hide
it cuz the whole time he was like oh we
can have sex until marriage and locked
her in do you think that's the same as
if if if a girl stuffed her boobs and
then like on the wedding night like
she's just got no boobs no because boobs
can be changed and then also it doesn't
it's not the the main thing in sex it's
not a thing that creates okay so what
out what if her what if she has that
vagina thing where it's like super -
super duper tight thank you yeah I would
that would be [ __ ] up - no but I mean
I feel like at that point you could use
like dilators or something you could
still work something off still beat
these vaginas though they just it's
closed completely
yeah do they even have like a canal I
have no idea boy I hear like there's
there's a canal you can open it how do
they Peden it's close close honey what
we've covered this before I wasn't here
for the episode there's another hole
it's a different hole it's on top of it
no I know there's a pee hole but like
but then isn't the pee hole inside the
hole and I'm a bio major it's like this
Casey you got this one and then it's up
here but don't the vagina lips or the
vagina lips are not what's closed oh
it's like here yeah I know there's like
this and the bubbles down here yeah
whole vagina the peepee comes from here
yeah but then it's all wrapped up in a
nice open the theater curtains the
projector is up here you see the [ __ ]
this is the [ __ ] pee pee hole please
what [ __ ] your pee hole
yeah doriel LNG key god bless
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]